what the is going on I like to party
Jesus honey wax this is unwaxed get in
lizard we're going shopping with Sophia
and cine Stone did we just become best
friends
[Music]
y I'm starting the episode hello
everybody and welcome back to a very
special episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters Sophia and
Sistine it's special why because I'm
back Sophia you did a great job holding
the fort down last week with your little
solo episode I appreciate it I enjoyed
it I watched it with
enthusiasm but I was clearly missed I
kind of needed to be there go no to be
honest it was very weird talking I mean
look Chris was in the room so obviously
I was talking to someone but it was like
I was I it's almost like you're
FaceTiming with someone on mute and they
just can't respond the whole time and it
was weird cuz I was ready to hear you
say something snarky or sarcastic at me
every time I brought up like a pie or a
moment I had when I was in LA and I just
didn't hear that so I was like oh this
is kind of nice nice yeah I was like oh
no it's going to CH why do you assume
that all of my commentary is going to be
negative not all of it but what what I
was talking about that day yeah probably
some of the things there there were
moments when I was watching it I was
like oh shoot I could have interjected
right here oh I would have made fun of
her for that an ology but I'm so happy
to be back I still sound a little bito
you guys can I just tell you something I
was down bad and this is for my parents
who said I was being over dramatic and I
was complaining too much and I cried too
much about my sickness yeah maybe I did
okay but when my test came back positive
for influenza and Co I left that part
out yeah let me be a little Dr trtic
which by the way I'm cleared tested
multiple times 100% healthy so don't
come for me but holy cow one thing the
sickness made me realize is how much I
appreciate being healthy I seriously
take it for granted like just being able
to get up out of bed go for a walk do
anything with a normal rational brain
because when you're sick as well a CO
brain is a real thing yeah I took it for
granted no you always forget when you
get a stuffy nose just that minor thing
about
much of a Nuance it is when you're
trying to fall asleep and you're like oh
God why didn't I appreciate the times I
could breathe with my nose it's crazy
you were you were bad and I I don't know
how I didn't get what you got guys I
didn't even get covid or flu and I was
with her I was coddling her when she was
super at her worst I mean the doctor
said the type of influenza I got he said
the only two people that get it are
super old people and people with a very
compromised immune system so all my both
of those for a good thing and my zinc
and my vitamin C and my celery juice so
that's the tri that's the the quadruple
combination that saved me I mean I guess
um it was also super boring you know it
was bad when Jennifer is sending me dog
puzzles oh to do alone in my room we did
we got like five puzzles I did some
puzzles I watched three almost four
seasons of Sex in the City um that was
depressing because I've seen it 10 times
already I actually hadn't seen it all
the way through this is my first time
watching Sex in the City from season one
on let me ask you this isn't big the
biggest gaslighter he's the ultimate OG
[__] boy yeah he's the worst gu he's
pretty bad it's funny though I I
mentioned to my girl friends that I was
watching Sex in the City and they all in
unison were like how have you not yet
like this is the Bible for girls and
everyone was just going off oh who are
you Charlotte are you Miranda are you
Carrie are you Sam and everyone just has
agreed that they want to be like the
sexy Sam but no one really first of all
you don't want to be Sam no I feel like
I'm
Charlotte
there's kind of I already know you're
going to say your
Miranda no one wants to be Miranda no
offense no one wants to be Miranda um no
you can see you as Charlotte I am
Charlotte I have I feel like I have the
goody two shoes thing going on but then
at the end of the day she still kind of
gets around she's a little freaky she's
a little freak like she does get around
does that make me carry I feel like you
are carry yeah you kind of are carry but
I feel like you Tred to be a Sam but
you're so not a Sam at all sop guys if
we no one knows we're talking about
don't even try to be a Sam at all I
haven't even seen another man's body in
like 3 years how have I ever tried to be
a Sam wow you just disclosed that but
you're not by the way grass is not
growing under your feet this girl as she
was sick was still has more dates than I
do in the last probably decade listen
time is of the essence and just because
the quarterback is down for two weeks
doesn't mean that I sto training you
know what I mean sure I'm still running
plays I'm still memorizing that book I'm
still out there so that when I do get
healthy I'm off to the races yeah oh
well you are even just after this
perhaps I am going somewhere after this
she is going somewhere after this but
let's be real what it's so frustrating
that the fact that he's not planning it
and you are you know
what I'm going to give him a pass okay
we're not going to get into it I think
it's okay you're a little more
unforgiving than me when it comes that's
not true I wouldn't say unforgiving I
just think a guy should plan it so
simple a lunch that's easy yeah but it's
casual it's casual like I want to split
a piece of banana bread casual yeah but
when you give some three options and
they still can't choose one I feel like
you know it's the lease that someone can
do you just want me to stay home with
you I'm I'm actually no I'm totally Fu
but here's actually my new approach to
dating this year and I've been doing it
and I swear to God you guys it's been so
foolproof I refuse to let another year
go by of me complaining to you guys
about my singleness and expecting some
perfect man to just come knocking at my
door no it's not going to happen here's
my new approach and it's been working
every single time that has worked a lot
for you lately I've been asking them
out hear me out hear me out Chris is
fist bumping in the air right now
support this thank you I have been
asking them out
because men don't always know what
you're thinking sometimes when I'm
sitting at a bar or I'm out with my
girlfriends one it's really hard to
approach you if you're with a group of
people two most of the time they're
going to just assume she's not looking
she doesn't want to get approach Maybe
she has a boyfriend she'll reject me
there's all of these reasons why you're
not getting asked out
yeah if you want something I'm not going
to sit around and wait for it to come to
me I want to make myself known to the
people that I want to ask me out that
I'm available so I've been asking for
people's numbers I've been making first
moves yesterday I asked a guy I think
we're long overdue for a dinner what did
he say Thursday 8:00 p.m. boom here's
the thing the worst that could happen is
that they say no or I have a girlfriend
or I'm not
looking life moves on baby I am so sick
of the complaining from Sophia the
complaining from me complaining from me
no because we all want a relationship
but what are we actually doing to get it
but I just feel like you you know when
it we always say this between the two of
us for one of us sometimes I'm the one
that it's downpouring then for her
sometimes it's a dry spell or vice versa
so right now I would say well not like
that I'm saying in terms of dates I'm
saying that right now cistina is in her
like Peak dating era like great lineup
of guys like going at it having like
this energy that she's attracting and
putting out there saying like I'm
available I think it's the energy and I
am just so polar opposite it's the
energy I think about 6 months ago I
thought I was open to having someone in
my life but I wasn't
exactly I don't want to say happy with
who I was but I don't think I was ready
to like give any more of myself to
anyone else I needed it for myself well
I don't think I was ready to let someone
in now I'm at a place where I feel like
the universe knows my aura is open my
legs are too I'm just kidding oh my God
that was a joke that was a joke but I
truly believe that I'm not going to wait
around for it anymore asking guys out I
think it's also so attractive like what
would you do if a girl was like I want
to take you out oh yeah right love that
why not it reads confidence also you're
setting the standard already in the
beginning of the relationship right why
not but then you think obviously the guy
though once you put it out there he
should plan it or do you think you
should plan it since you're the one
asking him out because people always
have that debate is like who is the one
to establish the dinner or whatever the
drinks you know what's interesting I'm
not so picky about what efforts are
being made on Whose part I think when it
like for example this situation right
now you were saying he should have
planned it I don't think that I don't
think that this casual meet up for the
first time over a coffee it needs to be
so reservation booked formal official I
think it could be kind of a mutual
agreeing now if he's saying I want to
take you to dinner and he's asking me
where to go that's different okay that's
fair but I feel like I'm only saying
this is because I watched a video and I
was reading about or listening about
feminine energy and channeling into that
and I was bringing I actually did bring
this up to you and and I know that
cistina and I are people that are not
the controlling is not the right word
but we're very confident and we actually
do know like the right place to go the
right thing to do like we will if we
were a guy truly we would be the best
goddamn dates ever and I maybe that's
just if I'm maybe I'm saying as a girl
being in a guy's body like we would know
but point being is that me personally I
tend to take over stuff very easily just
because I know I'm like oh I know we're
the best I ice cream shop is like I'll
just go so sometimes I'm like oh you
know I need to probably just some like
let the guy lead because I'm usually the
one that leads and it kind of
establishes in the beginning that maybe
I'm not wanting someone to be the guy
cuz everything else in my life I'm
very dominating in like I'm pry like
passionate in my career I also think
your expectations are super high so and
that's also another issue I've come to
terms with when it's dating I expect a
guy cuz I come up with this whole
scenario in my head of what he should do
the bar should be this high and he
should take me to this exact restaurant
cuz it's the sexiest low lit one
whatever and if it doesn't go the way
that you had planned in your head you're
already kind of disappointed so I think
kind of letting the rains loose a little
bit and just sort of trusting the
process a bit more yes but I'm not
saying that if he takes me to it doesn't
take me to like the top hot spot that
I've been dying to go that's not the
point I'm saying in general like I've
never by the way I've been to every
place possible at this point living in
New York with a guy that could be nice
it could be not nice she's busy I don't
not really um unfortunately but my point
is is like it's not the place I don't
give a [__] if he takes me to a dive bar
my point is letting him actually have
the confidence and leading and going hey
I want to take you here this is what
we're doing this is where we're going
and that that's alone enough for me like
that means oh I feel like very that's
look preference for everybody but I just
read about tapping into that cuz I feel
like every relationship I've been in
I've been very you know like I I would
the dates do this I'm like I don't want
to do that this year like I want to be
someone called me the JLo remember oh
remember the psychic called me the JLo
where um I want to be a boss of
everything but then I want to be the
princess in the relationship and the
problem is is like I don't know how to I
blur the lines between the two and so I
kind of which yes but the psychic also
said I was a little girl in my past life
who drowned but you're bad at swimming
so it's proba
true take it with a grain of salt but I
do think yes you do control the
relationships a lot I think this is good
self-awareness going into this new year
sopia would never ask someone out I've
been trying to convince her there's no
one I like see this is also another
thing stin when I said she's been having
this really good energy lately and this
is I'm power to you I'm like proud of
her right now because it has been like a
pause for a minute and now she has all
of these great guys that she's going out
with I'm so excited to hear about great
content for next week but what I'm
saying is you have the options and like
the crushes that you're interested in I
don't have one person that I'm crushing
on thinking about in my Orbit that I'm
going oh yeah let me go ask him out or
get his number or let me ask my friend
for his number there's not one person
that I'm feeling that and that feels so
weird how about
this how would you feel if I started
pitching you to their friends on these
so into that I'm into it listen I tried
to get you to out with the brother that
I'm going out with see you know I can't
do that don't you think that would be a
perfect scenario Brothers Soph and I
double wait side note from that like I
can't go out with this brother but other
note from that if this was a Poss maybe
in the future I'm not okay there's a
maybe future um but my point is that do
you think it's weird if like two sisters
go out two brothers is that is that
weird I don't know I is it is our our
kids cous just or not like like cuz
they're same Dean I don't know I think
it's smart I think we already know each
other the comfortability is there we
know our repertoire are banter so you
can say a funny punch line I'm not going
to step on your toes and I'm not going
to get jealous like other girls would we
can balance each other we could really
use this to our advantage I I understand
that but what if one of us breaks up
with a brother and then we have to go to
the wedding well then I'm sorry you have
to break up with him too then that's not
this is what I'm talking about like work
we're in this together I'm I totally
agree with that just you can totally lob
me up for anybody that's a potential I'm
in I would love to go on a date I'll do
it after this also how do you feel that
we look like twins right now sop you
keep saying you're brunette but you're
really not like you're like very honey
had a whole episode where I talked about
being a brette and can I say the amount
of comments of people going I'm sweetie
you're blonde andette not this is
brunette you you just have darker
Roots all your blond is still there
highlights dark I'm significantly darker
than I was before you can literally see
all the monitors I'm not like that far
off from
you no ha you're brunette you're
brunette don't don't get mad you're
brette you're brette you know what's
actually funny I've been having a lot of
facetimes with my parents especially
while I was sick and Sly has been giving
me a breakdown of every single guy and
the red flags in them and who I should
stop talking to so he's actually been
giving me some great advice okay tell me
well he made me cancel one of
them I'm trying to think if I the guy
with the tattoos yeah I said to cancel
him he sucked yeah um I had a bad
feeling him from like months ago when he
brought him up yeah no it it
just sometimes you know girls in their
head they think they want this kind of
guy and then there he is and you just
want to pull your hair out that's sort
of what I'm dealing with that's that's
fair I just I I don't know I feel like
you can totally feel someone's energy
immediately and if it's not kind of I
don't know know there my old ways of
forcing things to happen it was just the
whole thing like I could never picture
the two of you together that is so rude
just kidding I love aesthetically
pleasing looking couples is that like a
random oh my God oh my God why didn't we
lead with this you guys this is crazy
this is so good for waxed this is such a
good moment for our podcast literally
have no idea what you're talking about
okay a few days ago maybe this will be a
week ago now right my Mom and Dad send
us a video in the morning of them
watching the news and what do they see
on the news unwaxed podcast yeah it was
we were on the news wait did give you
like background on this a couple
episodes ago we asked crazy the simplest
question if you got to let from Hogwarts
would you drop everything and leave your
children family dogs behind so this is
what gets us on the news so it goes
viral on Tik Tok but we didn't even
really notice and also what she didn't
even notice how many responses and
stitches people were doing oh yeah to
the point we were on the news no we were
on the news so can you just imagine our
parents faces they're sipping their
Morning Joe in a phase they still woke
up still a little groggy all of a sudden
they see their daughters on the screen
talking about leaving their families for
going to wizard school to go do some
magic to do dark arts and I mean as a
parent right I was TR like
hypothetically that's the best part
we're all like yeah for sure we ditch
our but I'm crying as a parent
right you know I was trying to put
myself in their shoes I'm like would I
be proud of my kids for being like oh
they didn't get in the news for doing
something like charitable or something
like truly lifechanging they didn't cure
anything they made a Tik Tok no and got
in the news by the way I just agree with
that oh my God I'm cry the fact that
because it's all it's if it was
something else if this was the only
thing our podcast we've been doing this
for a while this is the first time it's
been like the news without us like you
know going for an interview or something
I would be so proud are you kidding you
wake up in the morning all sudden your
kid is on TV and you had no idea that
they were going to be on there even
though okay yes like it was a about
Harry Potter but overall I'd be pretty
proud saying like oh my God it got so
big and they showed our name our our
podcast whatever also I love the fact
that that was the day we decided to not
try cuz we were too tired to this is a
lesson this is a lesson and my mom
taught us this at a very young age and
we should have listened to her yeah she
told us when we were like
13 every time you leave the house dress
like you're running into your arch
nemesis your exboyfriend or your crush
because you never know who you're going
to run into and every time you look bad
you run into them is like clockwork and
then every time you think you are going
to you never do so tell me why we
decided to look fugly the day we get on
the news my ends were fried I was
wearing my glasses I didn't I was lazy
that I didn't even put in my contacts
like I actually I remember it was bad
you know what it adds character we seem
relatable we seem wholesome we're like
yeah we just two
girls you know look overall I'm proud I
think it's super baller I mean mom and
dad freaked out they're excited they
were holy crap the news the news the
news the news Okay so cinea is back in
this back in the chair and we're also
back in the city in general and we
always have been talking about apartment
hunting which has been very difficult I
think for both of us you guys you won't
even believe believe what happened to me
the other day yeah I am flabbergasted by
the unprofessionalism of this man Justin
reals are kind of scary I'm not going to
lie let me tell you something I was on
Street easy I was on apartments.com I'm
just typing away trying to find every
unit I can because the market is
terrible right now there's nothing
available I'm struggling I'm reaching
out to every listing agent on every
website I'm like please just show me
everything you have right so I had all
of these showings lined up next day I
come down with Co and influenza so I'm
out I can't go out I tell them all I'm
sick I unfortunately can't do all these
showings apologies right one of the
realators messages me right cuz he
started getting upset he he didn't
believe when I said I was sick also he's
never met me never set up a showing for
me never did anything so I don't know
why this internet troll was so
aggressive he sends me a
message just checking in on you are you
still looking to waste my time I'm sure
you were raised better
SMH so you
know my fingers went to war with this
guy it's just so unnecessary it's so
unprofessional I'm sorry it's not like
you canceled the day of it's a couple
days before but but I didn't he didn't
even set up a showing I didn't cancel on
him like literally he was sending units
I said oh I can't see any this week I'm
sick right he sent a few more I was sick
vomiting actually if you'd like to know
Justin and then he sends me this so then
I responded obviously not that you would
care about my sickness but please do not
undermine my character like
that can I tell you just the the power
oozing from s's fingertips and ears and
every open crev she thought she was I
thought it you know what she thought she
ate you're not going to lie I'm not
going to lie she screamed she facetimed
mom she facetimed Scarlet dad she's like
guys wait you guys reading that out loud
to both of you I really thought I was
going to get more of a yeah and now I
feel so give you finger guns what else
you want it kind of sounds lame now that
I'm reading it out loud I don't think
it's I don't think it's lame I just find
it so funny because when you sent it she
was like sent and she thought she honest
she was going to go off more that's the
best part was there was like a couple
variations but anyway it's been so hard
it's been so hard and the harder that
it's getting to find an apartment the
less I want to move I don't want to move
and you're annoying me because you still
want to and I don't like this and I'm
sad thank you sorry I don't know what to
say but no I I'm having a difficult time
finding a place as well I feel like here
is it is really like Black Friday for
apartments I swear those things get
swooped up yeah within an hour it kind
of makes me think like why do we
actually live in New York like why do
people live here what are you talking
about no think about it it's so
overpriced it's so compact it's so
claustrophobic you spend so much money
on a tiny shoe box of an apartment just
to be shoved in there when you go on the
street you're shoved next to people I
mean what is it about this place that
people are so willing to sacrifice so
many things in their life like their
sanity to be here yeah okay maybe the
quality of life is not the best but I
just think that people are just obsessed
with the energy of it you walk out of
your apartment you can do anything go
anywhere be anything it's it's that but
I don't know for girls like us we're I
have a theory though you know how some
people like to live in stress because it
makes them feel comfortable like we come
from a home of like chaotic stress all
the time so we sometimes like that in
our relationships we're like oh that
feels comfortable we know how to respond
to that I think New York everyone is
comfortable with stress and they like
the chaos even though it's not good for
them and it pisses them off and it
probably makes them angry and agitated
all the time it's comfortable for them
it's exciting it's fun I mean there's a
reason why we moved here he make it so
it's fun though I mean look I'm I'm
moving somewhere to be a little quieter
but I would say that this definitely has
been the place that I've done the most
things that I've ever done even compared
to La yeah but at the same time while I
was in LA I was thinking God damn I
missed this the glistening of the ocean
and the the sun just on a December
morning being 70 degrees not 20 degrees
and snowing and windy I will say that
though I have a question for you
okay would you
rather get a list of all of your crushes
or a list of all the people that hate
you
oh um think about it like people that
are crushing on you or like no people
that have crushes on you or a list of
everyone that hates you probably
everyone that hates me what yeah I would
go crushes yeah really why why would you
do that because I don't know I can make
someone have a crush on me pretty
quickly I [__] with that that's a
confident answer hold on Sophia is like
everyone already does have a CR no I
mean like I just feel like I I don't
know I just would rather know if someone
if I if one of my friends that I'm
telling everything to secretly hates me
and tells everyone else or someone I'm
working with like if what if my partner
is scheming behind my back I'm not that
I have a partner but I'm
like that's a no you want to know
crushes absolutely I just there I just
honestly I don't even there's no this is
why we're in a different place in our
life no guys I honestly care about to
know if they had a crush on me or not
we're in such a different place which is
crazy but s all the guys you're talking
to probably have a crush on you I hope
so I also don't think my list would be
that long quite frankly that's probably
why I don't really care about also I
don't think a lot of people hate me
either
so well I hope the list is zero if I get
it back from
hating um You probably have some ha
people you've
dumped that's valid actually they've
been running around these streets by the
way man we've been hearing stories our
little ghost of boyfriend's past just
out here in New York what's crazy is
that everyone sees them but us yeah and
here's the thing I I'm one of those
people where when I'm in the shower I
like to have fake scenarios in
conversations with myself I win all the
fake fights I'm I manifest things that I
want that never happened right and I
recite this speech almost every time I'm
in the shower since you and your ex
broke up of what I would say to him if I
ran into him on the street I think it's
a little late now I think it's extremely
late now I still want to say it you know
so bad you know what's so funny is I
always have those moments I think
anybody that has you know ended it with
someone or they ended it or whatever it
is has those moments like what would I
say if I ever ran into them again and
you think think about it and you go over
the list and then no but this is the
thing so there's so many variations in
my head I'm like I better be looking
good that's the most important part like
I look like I'm thriving I will be
thriving but I have all these things I
would say like either do I go in hard do
I be nice do I like do I keep it short
do I just ignore I honestly think
knowing me because you see how I react
anytime I almost run into anybody that
looks like a crush of of mine or an ex
of mine like I Retreat I think I would
honestly be just so nervous I wouldn't
say that much and then I would kind of
just go I don't think Bor well you know
also I would think about it so often I
actually gave myself anxiety if I like
would ever run into this person and I
can't I I actually cannot handle that
anymore see I would say I curse the day
you were born no that's so he doesn't
deserve
that I honestly think Sex in the City I
think I would just be you know what now
thinking about it because last year
there's a totally different thing I
would say this year and I actually did
have this thought I swear to God
probably two days ago I think I would
just be really nice really short about
it and just be like I wish you the best
like no problem with you like I do care
about you always and I want you know
have you kept up your end of the bargon
of um one of your resolutions your outs
of the year not stalking on Instagram um
I had the slip of a finger a couple
nights ago you can't just slip of a
finger what but but what happened but
but it happened because I was like
looking for something and then they they
just happened to be a part of the
pathway and hold on really Yes actually
though like I didn't like type it um so
I actually told myself and I was really
pissed at myself I go Sophia that was an
out like keep it an out there's a reason
why it's an out but you've been stalking
for me too I stock for you and I love
stalking for you that I'm fine with that
doesn't count yes it does I said you're
not allowed to stock for me too the fact
that you can name how about this here's
a quiz what's the zodiac sign of the guy
I'm going to lunch with today go that's
creepy that's weird what about the one
I'm going with on
Thursday um oh actually I don't know
shocking I don't know wait actually
actually I actually I take that back I
think I think he's a a summer baby do
you hear
yourself you want to hear the funniest
story do you remember this it was the
first week we moved to New York oh my
God I wanted to kill you for this and
the second day I lived here yeah I run
into this guy on the street I know it's
a sus place to meet someone we end up
like hitting it off it was great we end
up getting drinks with his friends that
night and our friends and somehow
someway you already found his
information and you already found out
his zodiac sign right so we were walking
and this is like my first time properly
talking to him getting to know each
other's jobs and [__] we're walking down
the street and Sophia and I are with
this guy and we're talking about zodiacs
or whatever and he says something and
Sophia says that's such a Virgo thing to
say and he looks at her and goes how did
you know I was a
[Music]
Virgo I start covering like oh like that
like little cartoon
like I'm a Virgo like I know that sounds
like a very and that's what I said I
said the reason why was because I like
that's such I I'm a Virgo that's such a
Virgo thing to say he
goes he I don't know he bought it creepy
creepy also he's a Pisces on Thursday
March
7th you're done I'm taking your phone
away I'm taking your internet away I
wait but first of all I think it's
extremely impressive how quick I can
find things on people extremely impress
you need to work for the CIA I actually
should be working in some underground
Pentagon type thing where I'm learning
sop I don't government no the U the US
government is not going to need to know
like what your ex's girlfriend's new
zodiac sign is I guarantee even the
president has relationship problems and
if he needs
to and if he needs to know what's going
on with the first lady have you heard f
you heard of the new trend that's going
around the orange peel Theory yeah so
and the ketchup Theory my question is
why are people testing their boyfriends
with like food but also it's such by the
way if my boyfriend was like can you
peel my orange he be like no your own
orange nor would I ask him to also how
about the one when they they squirt the
ketchup all over the table and if they
clean it up correctly so guys just to
let you know setting men up to fail I'm
not going to lie girls are really just
try to like catch their boyfriends by oh
there's three Trends right now the girls
are doing I find her so stupid it's name
a woman it's orange peel Theory and it's
also ketchup so basically the ketchup is
a girl will literally take a ketchup
bottle out of a their refrigerator and
just squirt it all over the table and
see if their boyfriend cleans it up for
them the next one is a girl holds an
orange and she says oh I don't really
want to peel the orange she says um I
really feel like an orange and then if
he goes and offers and peels it for her
and then the another one is name a woman
to be honest I wouldn't want to to touch
my orange it's kind of unsanitary I like
also I kind of love peeling oranges I
think it's fun it's like a little banana
we would be such good dudes I would be
such a good boyfriend I would be really
really good I well he the psychic did
say I was a guy in my past life you were
an old man yes yeah I was like a
merchant oh okay actually speaking of
have you ever seen the movie Past
lives no okay so it's
what's it called the the phrase while
she's looking Chris have you heard the
theory that men get pleasure from
pissing you
off I call I call Cap really I call cap
on this okay so I'm going to see if I
can remember this I actually saw it on
Tik Tok which means it's real um
basically there's this theory that men
get pleasure from seeing their woman
with an angry or pissed off face so as
long as that face doesn't laugh last too
long and it isn't to the point of no
return then they see it as a reward so
that's why they like to annoy their
girlfriend I don't I don't know if it's
a reward but you're getting closer with
the like like no it's a temporary so
they they have to gauge when they see
it's a temporary annoyance they see it
as a win they see it as a reward I'm
trying to think like what the girl
equivalent of that would
be I think I think the girl equivalent
would be pretending to be very angry at
their boyfriend for a while and just for
attention and they'll keep it going for
a little bit longer just to be like H
and then their boyfriend's like no come
here honey it's exactly the same and the
worst but the bad part is then some guys
are like all right whatever and leaves
it and then they actually get upset like
wait you don't care like why you
actually leaving it spirs into a fight
but yeah that's mom's calling me mom
called me too and so I oh she called you
first yeah cuz I had talked to her today
all right I call Mom every
day oh you guys are are you guys are
um yeah that's why I said that's why I
hung up on we're recording right now but
why'd you call Sophia
first um I because Sophia calls me every
morning and she's very consistent and
you're not okay Mom I wasn't expecting a
roast right now Mom I love having if you
asked me a question I'll tell you sopia
calls me every single morning we
FaceTime we have coffee and bed together
okay but mom who's who's a who's an
easier daughter
right now used to be it used to be you
what so I'm just the worst no but I am
easier s but I'm gonna give it to Sophia
and actually Scarlet is a very close
second she's actually almost easier than
both of you Scarlet is the easiest out
of the three of us I know shocking right
that's not true at all why don't you
tell Scarlet to turn her location on
okay we're not watching the football
game we got to go oh hold on one more
thing did you do any of the puzzles I
sent you Mom I really love you I got to
go I want pictures okay by love you okay
you hang up on her mid talk she'll keep
going she keep going okay so this is
what I want to talk about so the movie
Past lives came out and it won a bunch
of awards at every award show and it's
um it's good I watch on the plane it's a
little slow don't come for me if you
love it but what I was saying about when
we were talking about uh what we were in
our past life whatever they use this
phrase throughout the entire movie
called inun or I think that's how you
pronounce it um inun like I n Yu n and
it's basically saying like every person
that you meet in your life and you have
a conversation with was a part of some
type of life that you had in the past or
maybe the future it's like a fate thing
so even they say even just a nudge on
someone's shoulder when you're walking
by and you look at each other that there
was some sort of it's almost like an
invisible string theory in a way and so
in the movie
um I just thought this was kind of sweet
cuz I it's just I don't know I feel like
this kind of can help people sometimes
they say that like any relationship that
you've ever had and whether it works out
or not that in a past life you probably
were super in love if you were ever in
love with someone in the past and it or
and it just didn't work out that there
is a universe where maybe he stays or
maybe she stays or it's it's it kind of
is one of those things of P it's Destiny
that you guys were supposed to meet in
this life because you had met in the
past life oh you know what I'm saying
like in a past life you guys could have
been lovers maybe you guys were best
friends maybe you guys were siblings
like that's what the what if you guys
were related well I that's why I just
said siblings so you're saying that you
could be related to your
soulmate not related that's creepy
Sophia well maybe not related I don't
know that's interesting I just thought
that was sweet cuz when we were talking
about well now the conversation makes no
sense because we were talking about it
before then mom came on the phone that's
okay stop doing that you always look at
me like that you missed me didn't you no
I'm done all right let's wrap this
episode up I got to go get ready for a
casual Meetup thank you guys so much for
watching this week's episode of the
unwaxed
podcast and please go on to YouTube go
on to even our Instagram onox podcast go
on to Spotify Apple give us that five
star ask us those questions we won't do
it with anything less and we will see
you next Tuesday with again sinee back
you're so welcome bye by